renommierte forschungsinstitute
beschäftigen sich immer wieder auch mit
unserem sexualleben
während sich hier manches nie oder kaum
ändert gibt es einen trend der sich in
den letzten jahren mehr als verdreifacht
hat und das forschungsteam hat noch mehr
herausbekommen im mittelpunkt der studie
stand der einfluss von technologie auf
unser sexualleben und der ist immens
mehr dazu jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich eine der größten sex
studien der letzten jahre über die app
clou die den zyklus der frau trägt und
für sie und ihren partner zugänglich
macht hat das forschungsteam 140000
benutzerinnen und benutzer befragt eine
riesige daten und lager
es ging um technologie und sex und ein
ergebnis ist schon mal frappierend
digitale technologie verändert unser
sexualleben massiv und dabei spielt das
smartphone eine riesenrolle bzw die
rolle erst mal 30 prozent aller
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer nutzen
dating apps 15 prozent gaben an darüber
wirklich jemanden für eine partnerschaft
zu finden
zehn prozent sind auf der suche nach sex
für eine nacht over night stands
die schweden sind übrigens hier am
aktivsten mit 46 nutzt fast die hälfte
dating apps wie kinder
aber es gibt noch eine andere kategorie
apps die ziemlich beliebt ist
lernprogramme für sechs ehrlich gesagt
bin ich ja aber nur auf ein paar wenige
apps gestoßen aber sie scheinen laut
untersuchungen ziemlich beliebt zu sein
18 prozent nutzen apps um mehr über sex
zu lernen in china sind es sogar zahlen
da scheint es offensichtlich etwas mit
der aufklärung zu haben und jetzt kommt
es ja zwölf prozent der befragten
trekken ihren sexy legen also ihr
telefon auf die matratze und tragen so
zum beispiel ihren kalorienverbrauch da
wird dann auch noch tagebuch geführt mit
wem man wie oft geschlafen hat und so
weiter das ist schon lustig forscherin
amanda kesselmann vom cancer institute
dazu technologie ist
eng mit unserem alltag verwoben wir
nutzen sie um zahlreiche dinge die für
uns am wichtigsten sind zu vernetzen und
zu organisieren wie unsere umfrage zeigt
beinhaltet dass liebe und sex viele
menschen nutzen technologie nicht nur
partner zu finden sondern auch um mehr
über sex zu lernen die sexuellen
erfahrungen zu checken und ihre
sexuellen beziehungen zu verbessern
ja aber der absolut große trend gehört
mit zum sex er ist quasi inzwischen für
viele zum bestandteil des vorspiels
geworden sexting 67 prozent nutzen 610
schreiben also nachrichten mit sexuellem
inhalt oder schicken fotos um ihre
partner heiß zu machen und das ist
wirklich eine ziemlich große veränderung
vor fünf jahren war das noch ganz anders
da sagt noch 21 prozent dass sie sexting
nutzen würden
der trend hat sich also mehr als
verdreifacht veranda kesselmann ein ganz
klarer trend sexting könnte ein neuer
aber normaler schritt in einer sexuellen
oder romantischen beziehung ja wer hätte
das gedacht als es damit anfingen das
sex sind irgendwann mal ganz alltäglich
wird und so viele menschen es machen bei
bay
da die umfrage über eine apps und
tränken der menstruation waren nahmen an
dieser umfrage 134000 frauen 2500 männer
und 2100 menschen teil
sie ist also nicht wirklich
repräsentativ für alle geschlechter ja
wenn ihr mehr über dieses und alle
weiteren themen erfahren wollt dann wird
mir hier ein aber aufs auge und
vergessen ich denen
auf die glorie geht es weiter mit sex
ohne reue neue verhütungsmethode ohne
kondom und pille
wenn ja dann neugierig seid müsst ihr
unbedingt drauf klicken und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran